Now that we have our input set up, what we're going to do now is we're going to create our
interfaces and our initial
parent blueprints. So the first interface that we're going to create is going to be our usable interface.
We're going to do this by going to blueprints, interface, and then we're going to give this a name of
BPI usable, and then inside of this we are going to actually call this function useObjects.
So let's go ahead and do that now. So I'm going to hit ctrl space to bring up my content browser.
I'm going to do this in the root content folder. I'm going to right click and we're going to go to our blueprint
and we're going to look for our blueprint interface.
We're going to do BPI for blueprint interface, underscore, and this one is going to be called
usable, and then let's double click on it to open it up.
Bring this over here on screen so we can see this and then our function here,
and if you're not clicked on the function you can just click on it and hit F2 to rename it or you can
right click and rename, and we're going to call this useObject.
All right, so let's go ahead and compile and save.
All right, perfect, so we can close that down.
So what the next thing we're going to do is we're going to create a usable actor parent blueprint
by creating a new blueprint.
We're going to base that off of actor and we're going to call this BP usable actor.
And then inside of our class settings what we're going to do is we're going to go to our interfaces
and then in our implemented interfaces, we're going to click on add and we're going to add our BPI usable interface.
And any children that we make using this as their parent will always have this BPI usable interface inherited from them.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So we're going to come over to the editor.
I'm going to right click or I should say I'm going to hit control space to bring up my content browser.
I'm then going to right click and go to my blueprint class.
And we're going to base this off of actor.
So we're going to call this BP underscore usable actor, and then we're going to double click on it to open it up.
Now, when it opens up inside of the blueprint editor, we're going to look for our class settings, not our class defaults, but our class settings.
And then at the bottom, we'll have this interfaces and then implemented interfaces.
If we click on this ad, you can notice that there's a lot of different interfaces.
That's why we went with this BPI to make it easier to find.
So there we go.
BPI usable.
Now, when I add that and compile and save, I can verify that it has been set up correctly by coming down here and I should see my interface right there.
My use objects.
Let's go ahead and compile or save that again and close this down.
So what we're going to do now is we're going to repeat this process, but we're going to have an activate object.
So we're going to create our interface.
We're going to call it BPI activate.
And then inside of that, we're going to make a new function called activate objects.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So we're going to hit again control space.
We're going to right click, come up to our blueprint and we're going to make a blueprint interface.
So there we go.
So BPI underscore activate and let's double click on it to open it up.
And right inside of here for our new function, we're going to call this activate object and then compile and save.
Now, the next thing that we're going to do, like we did previously, is we're going to make a new blueprint based off of actor.
And then we're going to go into the class settings.
And then from there, what we're going to do is we're going to create a new interface or I should say, add our interface, just like we did before.
So let's go ahead and pop back over to unreal.
We're going to hit control space again to open up our content browser.
We're going to come to our create basic assets.
We're going to select blueprint class based this off of actor.
I'm going to call this BP underscore activatable actor.
And let's go ahead and double click on it to open it up.
And again, we're going to make sure we come over here to our class settings.
We're going to look for our implemented interfaces, B, P, I, and we want our activate.
So let's go ahead and compile and save.
And again, we can check to see we have our activate object right there.
All right.
So what we're going to do next is we're going to talk a little bit about our interaction controller before we actually make it.